hey youtubers is Charlene so huge news
they just announced attack on Titan
season 2 premiering spring 2017 so just
here's a quick breakdown and some
backstory if you guys haven't watched it
in a while the staff of the franchise
went to this attack on Titan Festival in
Japan they can basically announce that
they're like hey we're coming in spring
2017 new series if you haven't read the
manga the first season didn't cover all
the manga so you can actually read ahead
to find out what's going to be happening
during season two there's some big
reveals about the Titans you learn
secrets about what's in Erin's father's
basement but what has taken so long like
everyone's been shaking their fist since
they basically announced that they were
going to do a season two in November of
2014 and then we just never heard
anything we got a couple compilation
films
we got a live-action film that was
supposedly hot garbage people were so
hard on it that I just avoided watching
it so I have not seen the live-action
attack on Titan movie but spoilers for
season one so I'm going to talk about
the end of season one like the big
reveal and like the oh my god moment
that they left on it wasn't so much a
cliffhanger but just a reveal that was
like oh okay we clearly have so much
more to learn about this universe and
about the Titans so the big reveal is
that there are Titans inside the walls
of the city like the outer wall of the
city has giant Titans just sitting there
kind of in pseudo hibernation really I
think season 2 is going to dig deeper
into the lost history of the world
season 1 was all about introducing you
to the characters the idea of them
fighting the Titans they gave you some
of the rules of the universe then they
gave you a couple twists like oh my god
there are people that can turn into
Titans like you have Eren then you have
the female Titan because of the manga we
know who all the Titan shifters are
although I think they've only just
revealed who she is at the very end of
season 1 I'm trying to remember just
because the manga is kind of bleeding
into my head the timeline so spoilers
for the female Titan it's revealed that
Annie was a plant by her father she was
raised to infiltrate their society and
take them down so she's been trained
from birth to be this killing machine so
until she appeared she was kind of like
a Titan sleeper agent she went you know
she went into crystal stasis at the end
of season one so the survey corpse has
her under lock and key but there's still
at least two other Titan shifters that I
don't believe that the TV show has
revealed yet so season 2 the anime might
reveal that so for people that have not
read the manga if you want to talk about
story beyond season one just use the
spoiler tag because
they are pretty big reveals but one of
the reasons why attack on tight like a
lot of people call it overrated and I do
think that it gets overhyped a little
bit but I think one of the reasons why
people like it so much is because it has
such a rich cast of characters like an
anime is only as strong as its
supporting cast like you can have a
really awesome premise like one punch
has a really awesome premise but it's
cool because all the other stuff going
on in it is really fun too so even if
you feel like attack on Titan isn't like
the best anime ever it still has a
really strong supporting cast which i
think makes it a lot better than most
which is of course why everyone's so mad
that it's taken this long to get to
season 2 but that's actually pretty
normal for anime for like them to do a
run and then to just run out of money
and never do it again like oh my god
this is so amazing it's not like
American television like The Simpsons
will just keep making it to the end of
time because it's profitable so if you
kind of unfamiliar with the world it's
very post-apocalyptic series like you
pick up there's cities within these
walls so you get the sense that humanity
had this great war then kind of broke
down people retreated behind these walls
in big cities then nature started taking
over but then all of a sudden like a
hundred years before the show begins in
season 1 these Titans appear so now the
war is with the Titans they randomly
appear they attack the city there are
Titans with special properties that we
learn our Titan shifters that are really
humans who can take Titan form so
there's a whole bunch of new ones from
the manga that we're going to meet in
season 2 we're going to learn more about
the wars that humanity had before the
Titans appeared that led to the creation
of the Titans which they haven't
completely explained but in the
backstory like you kind of theorized
that the Titans were created by man as a
weapon of mass destruction so as things
got so bad for Humanity they retreated
behind the walls they kind of lost sight
of history so it's kind of like a Planet
of the Apes situation where you know
people forget that we're on planet earth
like you see a planet of apes like you
see all these Titans running around and
you forget that there was something
before they appear like there was this
big Great Society like there's even a
church now that worships the wall like a
church of the wall they believe the
walls are sacred
that's how long they've been living
behind the walls their culture is
adapted in that way so it's really
fascinating big world but obviously it's
so hard to make new animation that the
manga has gotten so far ahead so the
manga is really good like if you really
like attack on Titan you should
definitely check out the manga the
be careful for spoilers because they'll
be doing that for season two so let me
know in the comments like what do you
guys want them to do from the manga in
season two like very clearly we're going
to learn more about these Titans in the
walls maybe they're people too what is
it that they want why have they been
camping out inside the walls what else
is going on outside the walls there are
other societies there are other big
cities people that live outside the
walls but mostly season one is about
creating the universe inside the walls
season two will kind of pull the veil
back you Statue of Liberty Planet of the
Apes style where it's like oh my god
this is what's been happening the whole
time ah
mind blown I mean it's a really exciting
series because it's so action-oriented
it's so kinetic with the way that they
move but the mythology itself is really
well thought out really deep so I think
that helps a lot but mostly it's fun
because of the supporting cast of
characters I see you know like potato
girl the value of your antagonists like
Annie she's really mysterious really
cool character leave I wasn't really my
favorite character in season 1 even
though he's a total badass but he'll get
a lot cooler in season 2 just like all
the other characters so what's gonna
happen is is they'll probably release
another trailer to throughout the rest
of the year the probably talked a little
bit more about it typically they just
roll up and dump it on your doorstep
like here here you go your season 2 I
believe it'll be airing on crunchyroll
just like season 1 so once they announce
affirm premiere date I'll do another
video but if there's any bonus videos
that you guys want me to do for attack
on Titan just let me know in the
comments and be sure to subscribe to get
everything
when it does get here I will do weekly
videos leave the way it's just some
really awesome news this weekend that's
why I really like conventions usually
you know you don't always get trailers
sometimes you do but usually the actors
creators announce new projects you learn
about all the really cool stuff that
you're gonna be seeing in the next year
that's actually happening the United
States comic-con is going to be in a
couple weeks so there'll be a whole
bunch of Hollywood comic book TV movie
stuff going on you know like Marvel DC
all the TV shows so hit hype I will be
doing a whole bunch of Comic Con videos
when that gets a little bit closer but
if you guys missed it I did do a beserk
video for episode 1 but everyone seems
really torn on it like half of you guys
think it's like a dumpster fire and the
other half think it's really awesome so
we'll just wait and see for the next
couple of days if I do an episode 2
video like if enough people want it I'll
do an episode 2 video but if you guys
all think it's hot garbage then I'm not
going to waste my time on it but episode
2 of that will drop on Friday it's Simon
right now on crunchyroll with Japan so
why you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for that berserk
episode one video and you can click here
to learn why John Snow might be the true
king of Westeros so thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight